y cada voto cuenta
[Música]
esta consigna se extiende por todo eeuu
en medio de las protestas que exigen que
nada detenga el conteo de las papeletas
de las elecciones presidenciales estamos
aquí porque donald trump hizo un falso
reclamo de victoria díganlo conmigo un
falso reclamo de victoria
a menos que la gente se ponga de pie y
deja en claro que cada voto tiene que
ser contado la elección será robada a
medida que yo by the end ganaba terreno
el presidente de donaldson denunciaba
fraudes sin ningún fundamento su campaña
emprendió acciones legales e instó a que
no se reciban más votos por correo en
pensilvania a recontar las papeletas de
wisconsin y a detener los conteos en
georgia y michigan su llamado hizo que
sus simpatizantes acudir al centro de
conteo en la ciudad de dicho para exigir
que se detenga el escrutinio
[Aplausos]
vayan derrotó a trauma en michigan y
wisconsin por un estrecho margen la
campaña de trauma exige que sus
observadores estén presentes en el
escrutinio los ojos están ahora en
nevada donde el conteo continúa pero los
resultados empezarán a ser revelados
este jueves